I don't even know why. I think everyone was just kind of like, Oh, you're funny.
Or, you know, you just kinda.
Where are you funny? Like when you were in high school,
anyone think of Ken as the funny kid.
Oh, um, quite frankly, none of my critics think I've ever been funny. So I,
you know, I, I don't think I'm waiting for that to happen really. You know.
John's still, hopefully, hopefully, you know.
I'm being funny 50 years of charm as they say, but now I,
I really thought that, uh, I was just, uh,
there's a great line from, um, uh,
waiting for government is a Christopher guest moving and where Eugene Levy was a
dentist. He played a dentist who was, uh, like a poop,
had a dream of being a stage performer. He goes,
I wasn't the class clown as a kid, but I studied him. And so that was,
I felt like that was me as a kid. Like, yeah, like I loved comedy,
but I was a stressed out kid just trying to,
trying to get into a good school. That really was me. In a nutshell,
I was just trying to do my best in every, every class I had.
And I was really too stressed out to be a class clown.
I wasn't relaxed though.
Cause part of comedy is being relaxed and I don't think I was relaxed as a kid.
So then you got to, do you take this acting class?
Did you do any improv comedy or anything like that through your college career?
No, I kind of, we, we,
part of theater is doing improv acting exercises at night, just, um,
so I would improvise in certain acting games that we would have
and, and I just had a natural proclivity towards comedy.
And even then, I mean,
and then I started doing musical theater and uh,
they have a really great musical theater company, hopin horn at, at Duke.
And so I would do that. I would do Huff and horn and um, and then dude,
and then I was, uh, I actually applied to drama school and I got accepted.
Yeah. And, um, but they were,
that's where I had my crisis of uh,
of a crossroads because there was a fork in the road because I was either going
to go pre-med and, and continue on it.
Cause I was taking organic chemistry my sophomore year. And then I,
or I could go into drama class where you have to take, you,
you have a drama lab at your whole life is basically, um,
it is all drama. I mean all your courses,
all your electives everything's geared. So, um, and I remember the head of,
um, do drama saying, we think you could do both. And then, and I was like,
no, I there's no way I can do both. I'm not smart enough.
I don't have the bandwidth. I'm not that, you know, correct incorrect.
I even, even at 18, 19 years old,
I was painfully aware of my limitations and I knew that I did not have the
natural aptitude, um,
to fully maximize potential in both areas.
So it was really hard, man. I made a very difficult choice, uh,
after discussing with my parents. And of course they were like, you know,
you know, go with something when your parents didn't come down.
Hard for theater, they're like sign you.
Instead of waiting. Instead of waiting for Godot,
you should wait on your pre-med. No.